if you've ever wondered how video gaming
and arcade culture became a
billion-dollar industry then strapped in
for 8-bit legacy a curious history of
video games we're going into the
archives and down the rabbit hole for
the most remarkable and surprising
stories in videogame history to honor
its greatest pioneers solve its biggest
mysteries and uncover its darkest
secrets
[Music]
this is hey-zeus martinez de Vos
hizzouse martinez Silva's lives in Spain
hey-zeus Martinez fel Voss is a hobbit
superfan he learned English just to play
The Hobbit that's right play The Hobbit
because his obsession didn't start with
the book it started with him scare 80s
video game a video game that Phil
Mitchell and Veronica mega created but
before the game was released Veronica
disappeared hey Zeus Martinez Davos was
trying to find the person that changed
his life
[Music]
your gloomy and materials and the
creator of the best text adventure game
ever has disappeared now this is a story
of the quest to find her
[Music]
in 1982 Time Magazine's Man of the Year
was the Machine of the air the personal
computing revolution was in full swing
what was once a massive machine
exclusively for scientists was now small
enough to invade people's homes and
lives the Commodore 64 led the charge
its advanced computing power and wild
popularity challenged developers across
the world to make bigger and better
video games one small team in Australia
set an ambitious goal to create the best
text adventure game ever made remember
back then there were no computer Mouse's
just keyboards and words
so what could set them up for success
adapting one of the biggest fantasy
stories of all time The Hobbit our story
starts in Melbourne Australia with this
man
Alfred Milgram a video game pioneer in
those days we were still trying to
define what a computer game was there
weren't any guidelines there wasn't a
pool of people who knew about games are
Winton pine people from Melbourne
University two students joined the team
film was the programmer for the game
Veronica was the one who created the
puzzles she's the one who took the text
of The Hobbit and turned it into an
adventure game and she did a brilliant
job the game begins with a simple
sentence you are in the comfortable
tunnel life hole then the player types
in commands to move about an open world
in 1982 simple games like pac-man
but Veronica and Phil creating a complex
digital universe almost immediately was
a huge hit people were having parties to
play The Hobbit overall we ended up
selling something like quarter of a
million copies but one thing was missing
Veronica Veronica we lost touch not long
after the Hobbit was published do you
know what happened her no idea did
Veronica know her game was a worldwide
phenomenon that she had super fans in
Russia in England in Spain that people
were learning English just to play the
game my name is this was Martina device
and I love video games
for me the how it was the beginning of a
new world the world and microcomputer
and the wall of Tokyo it was a turning
point for me I always wanted to contact
the people that was behind the game and
hey Zeus he wasn't the only one fans
from all over the world were searching
for Veronica she wasn't really missing
but it was the 1980s they had no way to
get in touch with her until
birth of the internet with a quick
search fans now had Veronica's email
address and hey-zeus was one of the
first to write to her chair Veronica
your game Pat's hands my life I learnt
English because of your game thank you
for making the Hobbit all those years
ago with Philip Mitchell aloe vera Nika
dear Veronica the woman that shaped my
life hobbit game did and still does mean
a great deal of it
many thanks for the countless hours of
entertaining I hope karma has rewarded
you in your life for writing that game
because for all the price of page and
I'm still paying for all the rejections
in isolation being a geek is indeed what
I am what I love to be and what I'll
always be proud to be thank you
[Music]
pS escaping the goblin dungeon was a
nightmare
[Music]
it's not amazing
I'm dr. Veronica negra the quest ends in
Portland Oregon at okyun ask landscape
where Veronica leads a normal life I
[Music]
really had no idea of how popular the
game was up until about ten years ago it
was a part-time job I did at University
and I moved on to bigger and better
things
my PhD is in computer science I built a
big data such engine that combines ideas
from cognitive science and internet
search to work over archives of
scientific data so I am NOT a gamer
after I wrote The Hobbit I didn't play
any games at all for probably a decade
it wasn't just the fan mail that drew
Veronica out of the shadows there's a
lot of women who don't realize that they
can also be computer programmers puppet
this is my legacy and that was part of
the push to me to start stepping forward
and making myself easier to find just to
help correct that gender bias it's
pretty amazing how far that gain reached
and just blows me away and it was a
part-time job at university who wasn't
expecting to change in industry
[Laughter]
my task was write the best text
adventure computer game ever and I did
[Music]
crawling through underground pipes
[Music]
racing to catch a mushroom and saving
the Peach Princess all things you did in
the Mushroom Kingdom you might think you
know everything about your favorite
high-pitched turtle squashing Italian
plumber but you have no idea let's start
from the beginning the very beginning
guess when Nintendo was founded in the
19th century 1886 to be exact they
started out as a playing cards
manufacturer and as years pass expanded
their line of products going from toys
to instant rice and even taxi services
fast forward to the 1970s the company is
in dire financial straits and looking to
reinvent itself with the Golden Age of
video games in full swing
Nintendo saw an opportunity to join the
fray so they entrusted a young artist to
lead their initiative a man that would
ultimately change video games forever
this is shigeru miyamoto the
world-famous creator of the world famous
character Mario and this is how Mario
got his look the Madonna who knows I
mean they're the Mahato kazutaka
oh hi oh ho name is Damita ho city way
all of the Ariston opposed to other
American Apparel's holiday santoku
italiana nearest oka koto but that was
quite a challenge in 8-bit furthermore
mother Coco cologne was gushing are
there ma I know let's get there and one
thing led to another
having your heels killed they
communicated because that's not the boss
Chicago sale the secretary or online
limited who CTO a one itís a little
Mariano sighs honestly
now our character needed
well a name it's your banana captain oh
they're Makarov video game not there
mister video that video game was Donkey
Kong good career Agha
so no chinko no kanojo to toss her up
there sorry Oh a cockerel manic man can
only son and that's silly Hiro had a
signature move about tomorrow night
still right there I'm sorry ma bong bong
bong
mr. video became junk man a carpenter
climbing ladders on a construction site
but he needed a more relatable name
Sakai you know stole acharyas Amano
cocoon don't keep on the wall American
yoga pants
so todos somos de como a no hamburger
Minihan hasta la tarea - warehouse in
seattle to be precise and what happened
there a patent on oka a no so pannonica
so on
so no SoCo no candy no Rosanna Mario
sent you here I stole his underpants
that landlord was Mario Cigale and he
looked like this
what's a mustache neat they don't know
their weight so that guy inspired
Mario's name look boy you know I own
that bit so we had a funny idea we
wanted to look for Mario Segale a that
elusive landlord turns out he still
lives in the Seattle area and he's still
in real estate in fact he's quite a
mogul his name is even on a street sign
we tried to call him to ask about Mario
but he didn't want to comment on the
matter what happened in that warehouse
stays in that warehouse after Donkey
Kong our hero was ready to be a star on
his own so Miyamoto set out to design
his own a pom pom pom percentage our
meet Okajima Loretta hawaika token anima
negative alpha Papa determine if that
stone the daughter dr. Mario is jumping
over pipes so naturally he became a
plumber adorn Sri Lanka Kiku do you know
ho ho no superhero the American anything
instead Mario is kind of a chubby blue
colored girl Tina kimono character the
nice doll now sure you call her no a
solution optimal Oh
don't see a Scotty in players got to
enjoy even more Mario with his
doppelganger satchel Mario Buda Zaza do
you not like the digital photo
algorithms today most study mario Naruto
Chi idea most of the Madonna or not like
Mario his name has quite a story my
panda Guinea mario nazi you may like
that
reach it up and it was meant to be
losing wanna visit inova new Honda a
neat arrow to meet on the sill
although the Mario Brothers have a lot
in common Mario he remained the true
star and ultimately he's more than a
video game character
odo son poco de manera still Care Act
enacted today talk about trampled in the
castle - - now what do we see him pretty
much everywhere but we'll never look at
the Nintendo mascot the same way Mario
is a legend and so is his creator
Minamoto metalman or tsundere ji-woon
accounts terminal school - Oh cause
architect
[Music]
the Pacific Northwest has a lot of great
things going for it
beautiful scenery temperate weather and
a mysterious video game that is said to
drive people mad well let's turn back
the dial of it its 1980s and Cold War
paranoia is fueling a new wave of
conspiracy theories and in the city of
Portland that paranoia gave birth to the
greatest urban legend in video games
the previous story is like the holy
grail of arcades almost but the Holy
Grail can be something of greatness or
it can be your damnation
disappearance almost forty years ago
people are getting closer to discovering
PBS's secrets
you know is it worth the search to
uncover exactly what it's all about
well
we're about to find out
[Music]
welcome to part 6 of your training let's
meet the device you'll be working with
this is Bolivia's on the outside it may
look like an ordinary arcade cabinet but
on the inside Polybius holds advanced
surveillance systems perfect for
tracking user behavior careful users may
excuse some slight side invented the
Polybius machine the future of covert
surveillance between the 1950s and 1970s
the CIA was experimenting with
alternative ways to weaken the enemy the
program was called project MKULTRA the
CIA tested on unaware subjects using
hypnosis and psychoactive drugs in order
to find the perfect interrogation method
in 1976 the secret program was exposed
to the public
the revelation spurred countless
conspiracy theories that film producers
were quick to pull from movies like
wargames in The Last Starfighter
combined paranoia thrills and videogame
sensibility but movies weren't the only
things inspired by MKULTRA beyond the
theater marquees one of the biggest
videogame urban legends was brewing and
it all started with a mysterious arcade
cabinet that suddenly appeared in the
quiet town of Portland
[Music]
this is Logan Boden's I am director of
operations here at quota world arcade in
Portland Oregon
Logan loves urban legends oh yeah I love
them and he's kind of become a
connoisseur of the weird and wonderful
myths from Portland's past I've been
gathering the local lore as Portland
goes you quickly learn a lot about what
Portland was and the folklore that
surrounds it folklore like Polybius
Portland's most infamous legend which he
learned about while watching TV with a
friend
we were watching The Simpsons episode
that has Polly bits in the background
and he started laughing and had no idea
what he was talking about so he filled
me in the legend of polybius the short
and skinny of it is around 1981 this
arcade cabinet appeared in a few arcades
and the outskirts of Portland
[Music]
now if you played this game it was said
that you would have seizures fits of
amnesia night terrors
and also just a complete desire to
continue playing this game
so why would someone inadvertently
create a video game that had all these
effects perhaps it was on purpose
supposedly every couple of weeks these
strange men and black suits would show
up and they wouldn't take any money out
of the machines they would just open up
the back
supposedly maybe taking some readings of
data
perhaps a continuation of MKULTRA and
then after about two months just as
mysteriously as they appeared who
disappeared and I've never been seen
since and so a myth was born and with it
came a legion of believers and skeptics
trying to decipher fact from fiction
this is Brian Dunning he makes a living
debunking outlandish stories and has
heard many tall tales so Brian tell us
why the story of Polybius was a little
different it turned out kind of much to
my surprise that just about every piece
of evidence supporting the story was
true first two kids actually did get
knocked out playing video games in
Portland Oregon in 1981 seconds ten days
after that the government actually was
raiding arcades and taking games out
third we know the games were used by the
government for training and finally
there was a game called Poli play it was
a case where this game was physically
removed from every arcade in which it
existed so it seems like all the pieces
of the puzzle exist leading to a
confirmation of the legend right Brian
arcade culture is extensively documented
they had trade magazines they had
consumer magazines and in all of those
issues throughout the entire 1980s there
is not a single mention anywhere of a
game called Polybius we know for a fact
that it did not exist but proprietors of
the legend weren't quite willing to let
the myth die
[Music]
so they began to design different
elements of the game themselves
schoolteacher and dedicated arcade
builder Paul Santa Cruz is working hard
on bringing the legend to life
[Music]
one day it kind of popped in my head you
know what I'm gonna make a plebeians
but how exactly do you make a plea be
asst well in 2007 an underground
community of gamers actually developed a
hypnotic video game and marquee graphics
inspired by the myth it's what they
thought the game could actually look
like Paul decided to take the work one
step further and build a fully custom
arcade cabinet
everything was there that I needed the
graphics were there the game was there
so maybe the cabinet wanted to exist in
real space and time
[Music]
I wanted people to see it and stop and
turn to their friend and say wait a
minute is that really it
I wanted it to be part of that mythos
[Music]
so there you have it the story of how a
video game legend became an arcade
reality I don't think it matters at all
that the legend is true or false it's
just a fun thing to follow I had a lot
of people tell me the cabinet was cool
and didn't have any interest in playing
it because they weren't gamers but they
loved the fact that this thing existed
if Polybius didn't exist it does now -
the seizures in amnesia you're not gonna
like be a sleeper cell or are you
[Music]